do any of these sounds appealing danish
gambit grub
bow test whatever you want that's what
i'm saying
let's do halloween halloween gambits
yeah it's it's a month of halloween
anyway
it is it's time for halloween bye-bye
okay good luck and goodbye okay thanks
for the the input chat
oh halloween time oh i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be a victim of the halloween
accepted okay so this is a halloween
after knight takes e5
it's sacrificing a whole piece
um and it's supposed to be scary
um i should probably
let's go into this let's go into the the
line where i hold on to the piece
and see what he's uh he's capable of
f4 f5 is coming i usually have the white
side of this position
okay
g6 looks natural there's also d5
i'll play d6
the nice thing about being off a piece
is that at any moment
i could stack back the piece if i feel
like i need
need some room to breathe take this
i'm going to try and learn my lesson
from the previous games too
like time management
watching out for tricks
i don't mind this actually like the
summer pawns are not as scary
and i have the square to work with he
just wants to me me
did probably not face a good move
considering c6 and then bishop e6
it this one square is um
realizing rook f1
might be coming
maybe queen e7
queen e7 bishop g5 wow
maybe bishop e6 and then queen e7
i think it's okay it's really scary
though
it's not even halloween yet
oh castling also kind of does the same
thing
i could play this move queen d7
ah but the knight's coming in
okay so f8 is controlled by the the
knight and the bishop
yeah this is
this is exactly what white wants from a
halloween i can't play this because take
some knight f6
but maybe i could castle
run away from the danger
okay staying alive pawn chain is
jealous of this connect four
okay at least now i can develop and
maybe fight for that file
yeah he has such a nice time advantage
it's the thing about playing like
aggressive gambits
and getting the initiative early it
usually leads to uh
a lead on time it's just harder to
defend
than to attack
okay wow these pawns
have to show no fear idea rook f8
maybe not a 5.
i'm very happy with trading
oh i might lose a pawn though
actually i could take here first
you can trade some more
so he has two pawns
okay queen e5 i think makes the most
sense i just want to infiltrate
attacking the knight threatening queen
c4
not really caring about the pawn if
queen takes pawn i take and defend
this defends this lead sku thinks bob
valentine
have to think about what to play for
valentine's day
is there a valentine's gambit i don't
think so
okay knight g5 i can take it
i can take and check and win the pawn
okay i'm liking my chances
i've not won a single game yet i can
sweep this stream
okay the pawns attacked king d7 maybe
h4 coming
actually h4 is fine as i have 97
meanwhile i can keep winning pawns
i should have taken oh maybe it's okay
and now i'm fighting this so h5 i take
and i think it's winning takes takes
takes
b5
he's so tricky chuck
um
at least the queen's tied down to this
point
every game my time here we go
i'm throwing another check g3 then i
take
check oh
check
i gotta get this pawn rolling
i think it's going to turn into like
some kind of race
idea this maybe
this is so nerve-wracking
check
some other f5 ideas
oh how did i do this check
this is not what i wanted
i'm trying to queen that f4 though
actually i'm threatening queen f6 mate
wait a minute
takes here takes takes
push don't know if that works
oh
no
no
ah oh he's beating me again
oh he's so tricky let's actually try and
uh and fight though
so i have a knight in the pawn
it's not over yet knight defends this
pawn
oh my thing
yes let's go let's go let's
let's stalemate rosentrap let's go
let's go oh i feel kind of bad but
that's why you never resign
kids oh
well played though
okay i survived i that's one of the most
terrifying halloween gambits i've
encountered